I want to talk to you guys about uh that
TV show The Last of Us have you guys
seen it no no have you ever played the
video game negative so uh it's it's a
video game that came out I think it's
like 10 years old it the show is huge
right now it's on episode three they've
already renewed it for second season
it's got Pedro Pascal in it I think his
name is and it's really good three three
episodes in what's it about uh cordyceps
the fungus that takes over insects
bodies and turns them into zombies
mutates to infect humans Society
collapses fungus it's this thing that
looks like a mushroom make people look
like mushrooms a type of mushrooms
according to Paul stamets the world
leading Mycologist cordyceps do not eat
humans right I believe well that's the
point of the show the shows that it
mutates and does and then basically the
world collapses but the reason I want to
talk to you about this third episode
it's particularly culturally relevant as
it pertains to medically assisted
medical assistants and death and dying
or whatever they call it and the show is
about a post-apocalyptic gay
relationship and so the reason I brought
up is we're just talking about the
differences between men and women and
College and it got me thinking about
this so I just I like there's an
interesting Dynamic that I was talking
about earlier where you've got all these
people saying this is one of the best TV
shows ever made because it depicts a
prepper the world ends three years later
he's all he's all alone for three years
he meets a guy and then becomes gay I
guess because he wasn't before and then
it depicts spoiler alerts I'll try to
avoid most heavy spoilers if you haven't
seen the show but it depicts this like
story of them living together in the
apocalypse and then in the end the
controversy being generated around it is
that his one got one guy's like sick and
they're old and there's no doctors so
he's like I want you to poison me and
I'll die and then the other guy is like
I won't do it that's wrong and he's like
it's my life it's my choice and this is
how I'm going to go out and then he's
like okay fine and then I already warned
you guys major major spoiler alert like
it's in all over the news and I I I'm
gonna spoil it because you know it's and
I've already spoiled part of it but it's
because like the medical assistance and
dying thing going on in Canada the dude
then basically crushes up a bunch of
pills puts it in a bottle of wine and
then tricks the guy and poisons himself
along with the guy and then he says it's
the most objectively it's the most
romantic thing ever done and so you have
these two guys committing suicide
together and they're glorifying it
glorifying it and then people are coming
out now saying it's like the greatest
episode of TV ever made and stuff like
that and I'm like I gotta be honest it
was good
I mean it's a modern take on Romeo and
Juliet well the one thing I wanted to
bring up is
that yeah sorry like the gay
relationship unless it's no emotion in
me at all it just it just really doesn't
and then I'm I'm not trying to be a dick
to gay people like by all means if you
like dudes do your thing I got no I got
no beef but
what I'm hearing in the media is that
it's like it's so romantic these two
guys are like they love each other so
much the guy decided if you die I'm
gonna die with you and they both poison
themselves and I'm just like the
glorification of suicide that's scary
and then calling it romantic and I'm
just like I wouldn't find it romantic
it's tragic in Romeo and Juliet it's
it's tragedy it's not romance but what
we're seeing now is culturally
medical assistance and dying is being
they're pushing it it's more favorable
in Europe they're doing it yeah in
Canada they're doing it we had those
stories where like the veteran calls and
he's like I need help and they're like
have you considered dying and now we get
a TV show that I'm not it's not like
it's a young girl you know like a 20
year old being like I decided to die and
then dying or like a suicide because
that's that's depicted in shows all the
time it's like two guys who are alive
and one guy's saying you know what
today's my last day because I've chosen
it and then he's like let's go for it
and then they call it romantic and there
it's all heartwarming I don't know man I
just feel like
whether it's intentional or not this is
what we're going to start seeing in the
future yeah we already singing at Candle
where I sing it in Europe how long until
you think it comes to the United States
10 years suicide booths like in Futurama
I mean it's Oh Sister suicide is legal
in Washington and Oregon already it's
already there you go there it is there's
it's not a question I mean there's this
documentary called how to die in Oregon
I probably referenced it a million times
but this is one of the things that
happens a man is on you know State
Health Care and he has a tumor and the
state won't pay for his treatment it's
too expensive it's beyond what he's
permitted but they will pay for his
assisted suicide that's what they're
doing in Canada yeah it's I mean but
this movie came out easily 10 years ago
I mean this is something that we already
had and we're just seeing the effects
play out all the time I think what's
weird about this show having never seen
it is like it goes against what we might
say is like the glorification of like
the West right so like I've been
watching the show Yellowstone and like
all the other ones and like there is a
fight to survive right like if you're in
a post-apocalyptic world I don't really
know maybe you don't feel like there's
anything worth living for but like at
our core I think people want stories
where it's like but I push through
anyways because it was worth it because
ultimately we are like glorious in our
in our uh Victory so this was a
component of the episode like basically
and again spoiler alerts in the end the
main character goes to the house because
they were friends and then he's like
where is he and there's a note and the
guy writes this letter saying I used to
hate everybody and I hated everything
but then I realized I learned that there
actually was one person worth saving and
that's what I did I saved him I give to
you all my equipment use it to save
those you love blah blah blah and I'm
just like yo this at this show I I I'm
wondering if it's like
they're trying it's wokeness yeah that
they're having two they're two bearded
Burly looking dudes in a relationship
and I felt like
it just doesn't resonate I do not feel
this man's love I do not I felt nothing
from it in the previous episode Joel's
significant other tests sacrifices
herself she gets bit to save them and
blows herself up that I felt and then
what I did feel in the end of the
episode is when he writes the guys like
use my equipments to save to save tests
or to protect her but she's already dead
and so that was like brutal like all of
a sudden you're in this post-apocalyptic
world you have nothing no gas no cars
he's like they're showing like a plane
crash it's like we used to be able to
fly we can't anymore and then this guy
who's a prepper has all of this amazing
stuff and he's like it's yours now use
it to protect Tess and she's already
dead yeah that was brutal I feel like
this wokeness
I don't know what is this is this like
Democrat Prime predominant predominantly
females going oh they love each other
and then it's like moderate dudes just
being like yeah sure I guess you know I
don't know what do you guys think I
didn't see it but I think when two
actors are uh doing a love scene if they
actually love each other as people it it
reads in the movie like in the notebook
uh Ryan Gosling and the girl uh can I
remember that girl's name but it was
like just it's a gut-wrenching movie I
don't know if you guys have seen it
before I cried when I saw the movie but
they actually fell in love while they
were shooting that if these dudes in The
Last of Us don't actually have emotions
for each other but they're just playing
the character of a gay lover it's gonna
be you're gonna hear about it the the
lizard brain's gonna be like
you're like the seal in you is going to
clap but no one it's not real it's the
idea of it that they love but I just if
there's no love there then there's no
love there I mean I just felt like I was
watching this show and you're supposed
to be sad that these two people are in
love with each other and they're dying
and I'm like
I don't see it I don't see it I don't
feel it it doesn't if it was if it was a
woman I would have understood it yeah or
what if they were like Father and Son
yes
I was talking about this earlier
is like a guy and his kid and his kid
gets bit and he has to kill him you'd be
like oh man like so brutal or It's the
dad who like throws the cat out of the
way and gets a bit that was literally
the the second the second episode Tess
who is the woman significant other for
Joel they're fighting these things and
then she's like let's go and then she's
in there they go to this place and the
zombies find out or something and then
he like the kids like she's infected and
then he's like show me and she sees the
bite and he's like no and then she's
like get out of here and she sacrifices
herself and it's brutal to watch yeah
but yeah I was like if this episode was
like a guy and he he meets some like
teenage kid and then over the next five
six years he's teaching the kid how to
shoot and he's teaching the kid how to
prep and survive and then it ended with
him like throwing the cat out of the way
and then getting bit on the arm and the
kid has to shoot him and he's crying
would have been the most brutal episode
ever but two adult Burly bearded men I
am not trying to be a dick I don't care
if that's your thing that's your thing I
just I don't feel like that resonates I
don't want to see Brokeback Mountain I
did not I didn't either you guys see
that was it good I heard it was
phenomenal uh
I have no I mean the one from 2005. you
know Jake Gyllenhaal I mean I didn't
think it was that great I thought it was
just a cultural message I think a guest
that I had is that they actually started
to have emotional feelings I'd like to
ask Jake if everything happened but he
killed himself short like not that long
after like I think he was like doing a
lot of drugs really was like am I gay
what's wrong with me and then you know
it gets I I know actor in college that
did a gay a play where he was gay and
the other actor was gay and was just
loving making out with him on stage and
then my buddy hung himself oh wow many
like 20 years later but he hung himself
and it's like that he told me at one
point that play still sticks with me in
the back of my mind like as a form of
almost like pros like he was felt like
prostituted into it for the role because
it was a great role wow um anyway it's a
little off base yeah but it's not fake
like when you're doing these scenes you
actually do begin to feel these things
and if these actors were on guard from
that uh it won't play you'll know that
in the scene you won't feel it because
they're guarded from it
it's the danger of being an actor one of
the dangers of being an actor God you
know loved Heath Ledger what that guy
went through I don't know man the thing
about the the medical assisted suicide
to go back to that point yeah is that if
we're talking about somebody who's
bedridden the and and have has no way to
pay their bills and the doctor's like
you've got three weeks left and they're
just like well you know I'm in agony and
pain and the morphine's not cutting it
anymore like what do you guys think so
my question is do you think that
depression eventually will be used as
like a acceptable I guess justification
for doing this for going through this
process I think that just happened if I
I should pull the story really quickly
but there is a uh there was a girl in so
if you can prove you're depressed then
she will kill yourself she was it's in
Europe and I believe I'll look it up in
a second but wow there was a girl who
survived Belgium you're right Belgium
she um she was going on a class trip she
was in an airport and the airport was
embalming and she apparently developed
really serious post-traumatic stress
syndrome and had all kinds of issues
choose hospitalizawa attempted suicide
and eventually was granted permission to
go through assisted suicide because she
said her Depression was so crippling she
could never get over it and this girl
was like what 18 19. I mean she was
young she was young so you know what's
the limit you know are they going to go
I'm not saying I agree with that no no
I'm just saying in general like what's
the limit of ADHD is that gonna be
accepted I mean I mean it's like a weird
form of eugenics I feel like yeah right
it just eliminate sounds like you can't
hack it I guess acne I mean I don't know
like I kind of am
oh I don't really care about the
assisted suicide stuff I don't know my
crate I never have I'm like if you want
to kill yourself kill yourself who cares
like we've got so many humans because
everybody always regrets it they don't
actually want to do it that's what we
were talking the other day everybody who
jumped off the Golden Gate Bridge and
survived said the first thing that
happened was they regretted doing it
yeah so you have these people who are
feeling fear or Panic they're scared
they're in pain and they think it's the
only way to make it stop
and they regret it and so the goal is to
help them not do that because it's the
wrong thing like I knew a guy like the
guy I was just telling you guys about he
wanted to die so he killed himself no
one could stop him but then in another
instance I know a girl that tried to
kill herself a couple times and then she
didn't and now she's got a family so and
I assure you your friend was if he was
alive today he'd be like I'm sure glad
that didn't happen yeah I think so he
was like something Horrible's coming man
he was like really it was like 27 no it
was 2019 when he killed himself it was
like 2015 he told me like something
bad's happened he left New York City
he's like something bad's coming dude he
was like the best actor I knew too but
do you feel like because he felt like
something bad was happening it he should
have been able to kill himself right
like if you were in a position to have
influence over it which of course you
weren't it's a horrible thing to ask but
like
with with assisted suicide or what they
often refer to as euthanasia right like
euthanasia you feel like you're putting
someone out of their misery and that's
why it starts with these conversations
about people who are in very serious
organ failure they have very serious
cancers they will not survive and so is
it is it a higher quality of life to let
them choose when to end the thought the
problem is if you open the door to
medically assisted suicide it will
expand exactly exactly I'm a concerned
that some people if they want to die and
you don't let them that they will lash
out and start ruining other people's
lives and making the world a worse place
but that's on the individual level I
think that the collective consequences
of you know starting this whole like
medically assisted suicide trend is is
much worse and
um than you know the individual
consequences of you know one person
lashing out in their own Community
versus you know starting this Global
Trend right you know it also like it
also reduces the friction in doing so
it's very difficult to do it it's not as
easy as everyone thinks it is to just
you know go ahead and do it they said
we'll get drunk young people like get do
a bunch of drugs before they do it they
don't just you know if you make it a
nice hospital setting with doctors like
helping you do it and your family
surrounding you holding your hand saying
it's a good thing that's crazy exactly
it makes it way easier yeah more
romantic right yeah exactly it sure does
seem like they don't want a lot of
people I'm thinking of a pop cellular
apoptosis when you've got cells in your
body they pre-program themselves to die
like some cells when they're no longer
needed or they're causing damage to the
system because they're taking too many
resources they will kill themselves on
purpose to make the body healthier and I
I think humans are fractally doing that
similar thing I mean there are cultures
right where that's the expectation for
people who are too old or too sick
they're supposed to like remove
themselves from the society but like I
don't know that that is something that I
would personally be okay with it would
be really difficult for me to accept
that thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time